suite à la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle c'est aux collectivités
territoriales qu'il revient de fixer le
taux de la cotisation foncière des
entreprises
celui déterminé par la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines en 2012 a fait l'effet d'une
bombe auprès de la plupart des
entreprises du territoire
elles ont vu leurs cotisations augmenter
parfois jusqu'à 900 %
c'est l'ancien le l'ancienne taxe
professionnelle qui a été été annulée
par par sarkozy et qui a été repris par
les par les régions par les régions et
communautés d'agglomération sur toute la
france et qui avaient qui avait le champ
libre pour faire le pour faire un
nouveau calcul je suis passé de 280 3
599 euros ce n'est pas du tout le reflet
donc des évolutions de mes revenus
un 5,8 ça se saurait si on avait des
revenus qui pouvaient être multipliée de
cette manière là en 2011 de 260 euros
de mémoire ou 360 euros et lâche pas sa
1588 euros commerçants et entreprises
sont mobilisés comme au centre dumas né
à montigny où circule une pétition à
l'attention de monsieur le maire pour
l'instant elle a recueilli une
cinquantaine de signatures ces gens de
la communauté d'agglomération ne se
rendent pas compte qu'un chiffre
d'affaires n'est pas un résultat
il faudrait qu'ils descendent un petit
peu dans les entreprises pour savoir
quelle est la différence entre les deux
les maires des trois communes de droite
voisin montigné l'encours se sont réunis
mardi dernier et devrait faire parvenir
prochainement un communiqué ce jeudi
soir le conseil syndical de
l'agglomération se réunit à l'ordre du
jour le débat d'orientation budgétaire
cette question devrait être abordée
invité sur notre plateau cette semaine
le président de la communauté
d'agglomération n'a pas fermé la porte
aux négociations
je proposerai mois une délibération au
conseil du 20 décembre et au bureau de
cette semaine des élus en fonction de ce
que la loi sera modifiée
ce que le mystère ne pourra nous
permettre d alléger
devoir donc il y aura des ajustements
dès cette année ont tous comme tout ce
que le gouvernement et tous que la
loisne vers l'adresse bien sûr on le
fera pour effectivement rendre
essayaient d'éviter ces ces inégalités
ces injustices que cette loi nous fait
porter et en particulier aux entreprises